you know what I'm saying the opening
scene depicts a historical event during
World War One in 1917 specifically
focusing on the conflict between Germany
and France tragically we learned that
numerous young soldiers have already
lost their lives prior to placing the
deceased German soldiers into coffins
their uniforms are removed and sent for
washing afterwards the uniforms are sewn
onto new clothing which will be worn by
the next batch of soldiers it has been
three years since the War Began and we
are introduced to a 17 year old boy
named Paul Baumer who along with his
school friends Albert cropp Franz
Mueller and Ludwig bem enlists their
names in the Imperial German Army it is
revealed that Paul's mother has
forbidden him from joining the Army but
Franz convinces him to forge her
signature on the approval letter one day
the group listens to a patriotic speech
by a school official after which they
received their uniforms unaware of the
fact that they belong to the fallen
soldiers from a previous battle
oblivious to the harsh realities and
cruelty of the battlefield these young
boys are motivated to go to war only to
be perceived as cool people in the eyes
of the public the next day the boys are
deployed to northern France near La
malmesan after arrival at the base camp
a doctor blocks their path and asks that
the soldiers vacate their vehicle in
order to transport injured comrades to
the hospital from there they all proceed
to walk towards the battlefield after a
long walk they reach their hiding spot
where they meet other soldiers and a
vice Commander named Stanislaus
katsinski during their first night in
the trenches Paul and Albert are
assigned to keep watch a short while
later they hear footsteps and become
alert so Paul prepares his weapon and
scans the area for any signs of movement
upon spotting something amiss he
instinctively opens fire inadvertently
revealing their location in response the
enemy retaliates and shoots up Paul's
head but fortunately his helmet Shields
him from the bullet the next second the
enemies launch a brutal attack forcing
all the German soldiers to seek Refuge
inside a bunker as the assault
intensifies Paul and and his friends are
forced to hide since they lack Advanced
Weaponry to counter the enemy the boy's
idealized perception of War crumbles as
they confront its Grim realities
unfortunately due to the continuous
bombarding the bunker collapses trapping
and killing some of the soldiers under
the rubble in the morning Paul who is
still buried under debris is rescued by
Albert and the other soldiers
overwhelmed and traumatized Paul takes a
moment to rest it is during this time
that stenislavs a compassionate leader
unlike the others offers Paul a piece of
bread and lets him know about the
horrors of War shortly after Paul is
assigned to the task of retrieving
identification tags from the deceased
soldier's necks while doing so he comes
across the lifeless body of his friend
Ludwig which brings him to tears Paul
takes a moment to grieve and mourn the
loss before continuing with his task the
scene then shifts to 18 months later
where we witness a meeting between a
German State secretary named Matthias
erzberger and the German High command
maritzburger weary of the mounting
losses tries to convince the high
command to initiate Armistice
negotiations with the Allied powers back
on the battlefield Paul appears to have
grown accustomed to the harsh reality of
War one day while walking with Stanislas
they stumble upon a small farm near the
forest craving to eat something tasty
after a long time they plan to steal
livestock from the farm Stanislaus
enters the premises while Paul keeps a
watch outside after successfully
stealing a pet they quickly run away
from the scene they then return to the
base and cook the stolen food Albert
France and another soldier named Jaden
join them and have a wonderful meal
amidst this they also joke and laugh
creating a joyful atmosphere and
forgetting the bitter reality of War for
some time that farmer is pissed though
the following morning as the soldiers
prepare their breakfast they spot three
women passing by having been deprived of
female companionship for a long time
they are captivated by their presence
Franz even goes a step further and
approaches the women offering to escort
them home later that day the soldiers
received letters from their families
since Dennis Laos is illiterate he asks
Paul to read a letter from his wife the
letter describes how much she misses
stenislaus and her desire for them to
visit their son's grave together after
hearing this Stanislaus says that he
feels like a loser as his child had been
sick for an extended period of time
before passing away but he was unable to
visit his son even for a single time
furthermore he worries that he will be
unable to reintegrate into peacetime
Society according to Stanislas the
government's Promises of substantial
salaries have trapped them but in
reality the actual value of the wages is
worthless especially considering the
uncertainty of survival until the wars
end that same night Franz returns to his
fellow soldiers and recounts his
experience with the women he brings a
handkerchief belonging to one of them as
a Keepsake offering it to Paul to sniff
it and experience the woman's scent
don't laugh it's not perverted it's
touching the next day Paul Albert Franz
Stanislaus and Jaden are assigned to the
task of locating the dead bodies of 60
soldiers who fell during the recent
attack in France near an abandoned rail
track while searching Stanislaus detects
a lingering trace of poisonous gas used
by the French earlier suspecting that
the soldiers may have sought shelter in
the area the group enters a nearby
Warehouse they carefully search the area
and eventually discover a room
containing the lifeless bodies of all 60
soldiers upon witnessing the horrific
site Stanislaus says that the soldiers
must have succumbed to an excessive dose
of poisonous gas likely due to premature
removal of their gas
on the other hand aritzburger and some
other German delegates board a train to
the forest of compien for ceasefire
negotiations however a general named
friedrichs opposes the idea of hermistus
talks believing that the French will
seek unfair terms he still hopes that
Germany can win the war despite lacking
Advanced Equipment as a result General
friedrichs instructs his men to prepare
for an attack before French
reinforcements arrive that night
ertzberger and the delegates arrive at
the forest of compian while Paul's
regiment is dispatched to the front
lines to prepare for an assault on the
French the next morning the German
delegates led by azberger meet with
their French counterparts and request a
ceasefire highlighting the significant
loss of German soldiers in the conflict
the French Supreme Allied Commander
presents a negotiation contract granting
the Germans 72 hours to accept the
non-negotiable terms imposed by the
Allies however until the treaty is
signed the war will continue unabated
meanwhile on the battlefield the German
soldiers initiate their attack engaging
in Fierce Close Quarters combat cure the
French front line unfortunately their
progress is short-lived as they face a
combined arms counter-attack with the
French using Saint shimond tanks to
overpower the German defenses despite
their attempts to fight back against the
tanks the German soldiers bullets have
minimal effect leaving them vulnerable
as the tanks relentlessly Crush their
positions in addition the French
soldiers use Advanced flamethrowers to
torch their enemies and poor Albert
becomes one of the victims of the Flames
Paul witnessing this horrifying sight
experiences a wave of panic but manages
to continue retreating back to their
trench once he gets there the commander
immediately orders Paul to gather as
much ammunition as possible and Retreat
without time for contemplation Paul
hastily does is asked and begins to run
towards safety but unfortunately along
the way he falls into a crater in the
treacherous no man's land now with the
enemies approaching he acts quickly and
pretends to be dead but to his dismay he
notices a French soldier standing behind
him poised to shoot it appears as if
Paul is going to meet his end but just
then a German comrade arrives at the
scene and shoots the French soldier
causing him to fall into the same crater
seizing this opportunity Paul grabs his
knife and repeatedly stabs the French
soldier as Paul watches him die slowly
he becomes overwhelmed by guilt so he
begs for forgiveness from the lifeless
body while searching the French
soldier's belongings Paul discovers a
photograph of the soldier's family this
only intensifies his guilt and he begins
crying like a baby back in the Train the
German delegates go through the terms of
negotiation which seems to Corner
Germany hence a senior official objects
stating that signing the agreement would
be seen as surrender he would rather
lose the war with honor however
erzberger argues that the decision
should not be based solely on winning or
losing but on the thousands of young
German soldiers who are desperately
fighting a war which is unwinnable a few
hours after sending the agreement copies
to the higher government officials
aritzburger receives instructions from
the field Marshal to accept the Allied
terms following this the delegates from
both countries meet for further
negotiations
ertzberger assures the French delegates
that their government will make every
effort to fulfill France's conditions he
along with the two other German
delegates signs an Armistice agreement
set to take effect at 11 am the very
next day with this the French delegates
finally declare the end of the war
elsewhere Paul makes his way back to the
base and discovers the soldiers
rejoicing over the impending end of the
war inside the medical facility he finds
Jaden who is seriously wounded in the
legs it appears as if he is never going
to walk again Jaden then brings out
franz's scarf and reveals that the poor
boy also succumbed to his injuries
devastated by the loss of his friends
Paul ties Francis handkerchief around
his neck as a tribute with a heavy heart
he then heads to the kitchen where he
reunites with Stanislaus together they
bring food for Jaden and provide him
with a spoon and fork to eat up
tragically Jaden who is distraught at
being crippled commits the unthinkable
with the same Fork the following morning
the news of the official ceasefire
reaches the soldiers at the base camp as
Paula seconds you find Stanislaus
staring out of the window when
questioned Stanislaus expresses that it
is the most peaceful day since he came
to the war because For the First Time in
four years he hasn't heard a single
sound of gunshots in order to celebrate
their Newfound Freedom the two friends
decide to steal from the farm once more
along the way Stanislaus excitedly says
that he cannot wait to return home and
hug his beloved wife tightly after some
time walking they finally arrive at the
farm Paul silently gets inside while
Stanislaus stands slaus guard Paul comes
across some duck eggs and stuffs them in
his pocket but during this he is
apprehended by a young boy who quickly
summons his father the latter realizes
that he is again being robbed so he
grabs his gun and opens fire on Paul
luckily the Two Soldiers managed to
escape unscathed once at a safe distance
they crack open the eggs and take turns
eating them as Stanislaus steps away to
take a leak in the forest the farm
owner's son suddenly appears from behind
aiming his gun at them the next second
Paul hears a gunshot so he rushes to
stennis last only to find him wounded
the bullet appears to have penetrated
the right part of his stomach horrified
Paul carries his injured comrade back to
the base for Medical Aid but despite his
best efforts stennis less tragically
passes away due to excessive loss of
blood this shatters Paul as he has now
witnessed the loss of all of his friends
the war has totally broken him later on
all the soldiers are called to assemble
in the courtyard where General
friedrichs delivers news that they will
soon be returning home back to their
families however in a surprising twist
friedrichs driven by his desire for
German Victory contemplates one final
attack to commence it 10 45 a.m just
before the scheduled ceasefire at 11. he
orders the soldiers to capture territory
before the ceasefire takes effect
disregarding the potential loss of lives
it would lead despite their reservations
the soldiers are compelled to obey these
higher orders in the next scene the
soldiers reluctantly make their way back
to the battlefield launching the attack
precisely at 10 45 am as per the order
Paul engage ages in combat relentlessly
eliminating as many French soldiers as
possible in the midst of the chaos Paul
comes to the aid of a young German
recruit but in the process he becomes
the target of a French soldier both Paul
and the French soldier tumble into a
bunker as they stand face to face they
freeze for a moment hoping that the
clock will strike 11. however their
encounter is abruptly interrupted when
another French soldier fatally stabs
Paul right in the Heart from behind
seconds later the war is officially
declared over and the sound of
Commander's voices shouting ceasefire
resonates through the air with his last
bit of strength Paul stumbles out into
the trenches relishing the end of the
war before finally succumbing to his
injuries short while later a newly
arrived German recruit whom Paul had
previously saved is tasked with
collecting identification tags from
Fallen Soldiers as the recruit carries
out this Grim Duty he comes across
Paul's lifeless mud-covered body in a
gesture of respect he picks up franz's
Scar from him and wraps it around his
own neck however the recruit chooses not
to take Paul's ID tag resulting in his
death going unrecorded this means that
the brave Paul will forever remain
unknown in official records subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for